après le collège court bell il ya une
semaine ce sont les enseignants de youri
gagarine qui se mobilisaient ce lundi
matin à trappes environ 30 de la
quarantaine de professeurs n'ont pas
assuré leurs cours une grève contre la
dotation horaire globale attribuée à
leur établissement situé en zone
d'éducation prioritaire en force est
calculée par l'académie cette dotation
permet de déterminer le nombre de
classes en fonction du nombre d'élèves
selon ces enseignants qui ont reçu le
soutien du maire de trappes il faudrait
deux classes supplémentaires à la
rentrée prochaine le calcul qui a été
fait par l'inspection académique pour
nous ne correspond pas à la réalité dieu
du collège actuel et à la réalité de la
rentrée prochaine on se retrouve avec
des classes un petit peu plus chargé et
à chaque fois qui dit des classes un
petit peu plus chargé 10 des professeurs
moins disponibles pour chaque élève on a
ici une secte pas on a des enfants aussi
qu'ils ont du mal avec le français
parfois qui ont eu du retard scolaire et
pour les accompagner convenablement leur
permettre de réussir et ne pas les
condamner à l'échec dès le plus jeune
âge eh bien il faut mettre le paquet de
son côté l'académie de versailles joint
par notre rédaction assure poursuivre
son engagement pour une répartition
équitable des moyens entre
établissements au collège gagarine c'est
la baisse constante des élèves qui
justifie la dotation pour la rentrée
prochaine l'établissement de plus de 400
élèves auraient perdu près de 80 jeunes
en quatre ans pour la rentrée 2022 une
baisse de 37 élèves est prévue sur le
secteur de recrutement du collège la
dotation horaire globale traduit donc
l'évolution des effectifs au sein du
collège avec 37 élèves en moins
l'établissement comptera une classe en
moins les moyens mis à disposition du
collège permettront de maintenir en
moyenne 25 élèves par classe 25 dans un
collège comme le nôtre c'est déjà trop
donc la base qui est choisie par le
rectorat de dire à 25 vous serez bien
c'est une base qui est faussé autre
grief pour ces professeurs la mauvaise
répartition des élèves dans les trois
collèges de la ville
youri gagarine et gustave courbet perdre
des effectifs alors que celui du village
est surchargé ils craignent à terme
comme conséquence des suppressions de
postes et demandent une refonte de la
carte scolaire au conseil départemental
des yvelines compétent en la matière
sans réponse pour le moment la
collectivité n'a pas souhaité s'exprimer
sur le sujet à notre micro les
professeurs mobilisés seront reçus ce
lundi soir par l'inspection académique
il n'exclut pas d'autres actions dans
les prochains jours